[Music]
coming up on fyi after boris johnson
quit as prime minister what happens next
who will be our next prime minister and
how will he or she be chosen i'm at
westminster where all the big decisions
are made by politicians
[Music]
and is your school short of musical
instruments you're not alone we'll be
asking whether we're getting enough help
to learn to play music plus we'll speak
to the stars of the latest zombies film
addison
[Music]
this is fyi the weekly new show where we
bring you all the latest info even in a
sling hey maya what happened well i fell
at school and fractured my elbow but i'm
all good great well like us you might be
wondering after boris johnson quit when
will we get a new prime minister and how
is one chosen well we sent thomas to
westminster to get more info hey thomas
hi guys so behind me is the houses of
parliament where all the politicians
work and we've been told it's business
as usual with boris johnson still in
charge until the replacement is found
and loads of politicians from his party
the conservatives are putting their
names forward so from what i gather the
conservative party gets to choose our
new leader so why does a political party
get to vote for our new prime minister
and not adults from across the uk that
seems a bit unfair
yeah it does until you read up on how it
all works and then you kind of get it
this is what i found out
[Music]
so three years ago there was a general
election when people over the age of 18
get to vote on which political party
will run the country
they do that by voting for someone to
represent the area where they live
that person is usually a member of a
political party
the person with the most votes in each
area gets a seat here in the house of
commons to vote and debate on policies
and new laws usually a party with the
most mps winning seats gets what is
called a majority and becomes the
government
basically a team of mps that runs the
country
the leader of that party becomes prime
minister
the conservative party won the last
election and now its mps have made it
clear they don't want boris johnson to
be their leader he has agreed to step
aside
the party will have their own election
to decide who will be their next leader
thank you all very much
thank you
politicians from other political parties
have said that there really should be a
general election so the public can
decide but they don't have the power to
force one to happen who said politics
was boring
a lot of conservative mps put their
names forward
so we wanted to get your shout on boris
johnson resigning and what you want from
a new prime minister over to the fyi
news club members at southgate school
[Music]
it is clearly now the will
of the parliamentary conservative party
that there should be a new leader of
that party and therefore a new prime
minister and i've agreed with segren
brady the chairman of our backbench mps
that the process of choosing that new
leader should begin now the things i
liked about boris johnson was probably
he dealt with the lockdown quite well
and we were one of the first european
countries to get the vaccine out one of
the things i disliked about him is that
he tend to make rules that he wouldn't
follow himself i think we just need a
trusted leader uh you know someone we
can rely on to lead the country someone
who we can trust and who will deliver on
what they say i don't really trust
politicians i think the public should be
on full control of who is ruining the
country because at the end of the day
they're the ones that are getting
affected by the leaders choices so
if if you can't choose then it doesn't
become a free country anymore the things
that i want the government to prioritize
is cutting the costs of like everyday
necessities yeah i think there's like a
lot of people out there that happen to
choose between heating and food and
petrol as well that cost a lot of money
so it's not really fair that people that
can't afford it are having to pay
remember if you want to have your say on
an issue right here on fyi head to our
webpage at first.news fyi you'll get all
the info on how to set up an fyi news
club at your school
[Music]
so scarlett a little birdie told me that
you play the piano yeah i love playing
the piano but i just really enjoy music
in general yeah i play piano as well but
some of our teachers think the
government isn't doing enough to give us
all an opportunity to play musical
instrument at school did you know that
right now school pupils in england don't
get free access to musical instruments
or to musical lessons but in scotland
and wales they do really yeah but there
are loads of organizations and charities
trying to get musical instruments into
school for free like the brass
foundation scheme which has taken place
in gloucestershire pupils from one of
the schools they helped wanted to show
us how it transformed their world
[Music]
these guys are getting ready for their
end of term performance one two three
four
when they first picked up their brass
instruments they didn't have to buy or
rent them they borrowed them without
having to pay a penny
i
think music is peaceful i find it
calming but also if it's like
like really cool music i just find it
really exciting i just like playing
tunes to entertain myself and there's a
lot of things you can do with music you
could end up playing in orchestras or
bands and stuff
they only started learning their
instruments at the start of the term and
now it's finally time for their prom in
the playground
[Music]
i don't think i would have tried a
brass instrument unless they came and
told us we could do it for free you
usually have to rent them
buying one is over 500 pounds sometimes
everyone should have the opportunity to
play
if they want i think it's unfair that
how if they can't afford it i think they
still should
should be able to it's just a really fun
exciting experience and it can really
help you and it's not fair that only
people with enough money should get i
think music should be free in every
school
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
they did great so maya it's with in
scotland and wales people get access to
musical instruments and lessons for free
but they don't in england yeah i
actually did an internet search on it
and the government says that they're
planning to spend over 100 million
pounds more on music education so does
that mean that we'll be getting more
access to musical instruments and
lessons then
hopefully i've got a hold of paul
mclaughlin he's in charge of the scheme
that helped the pupils that we just saw
perform
hi there paul thanks for joining us hi
so what do you think about the
government announcing extra funding for
musical education in schools
i think it's a great thing any
added funding coming in that makes our
jobs a bit easier makes more people have
the opportunity to access music whether
that's playing or listening can only be
a good thing it sounds like loads of
money though and it's not going to go
very far
but without wishing to sound cynical
about it anything that comes in isaiah
has to be a good thing and i think it's
great that the government has finally
recognized the work that we do as
musicians and as music teachers and the
hard work that schools and other
organizations like community brass bands
put in working with young people
bringing them through into an
environment that is a lifelong pleasure
well thank you so much for your time
paul bye thank you
more than usual this week we're all
talking about the weather and how hot
it's been in most parts of the uk
there's been a heatwave and the met
office the uk's weather organization has
even issued rare health warnings because
of high temperatures yeah it's been so
hot and because of that people have been
going swimming outdoors which has led to
a number of teenagers drowning in canals
quarries and even the sea so police have
now said to only swim in supervised
areas yeah well i'm on the royal
national lifeboat institution website
now and they have loads of advice on how
to stay safe in the water
if you go to the beach best choose one
with a lifeguard where flags show you
where it's safe to swim
if you're in the water and in trouble
you should form a star shape to float
and call for help
if you see someone in trouble call 999
so this heatwave got us wondering is
whether like this normal or a heatwave
is going to become more frequent in the
uk and is that down to climate change
we've got a hold of meteorologist joe
robinson who knows all about the weather
to tell us more
extreme heat waves do occur naturally
due to changing weather patterns across
the globe but heat waves are becoming
more frequent longer and more intense as
global temperatures rise due to human
activity
in fact three out of the last four
summers somewhere in the uk recorded 35
degrees celsius or higher
but our climate is changing and so are
the thresholds used by the met office to
define a heatwave
they were changed earlier this year in
line with the most recent climate period
and that in turn raised some of the
levels across eastern parts of england
thanks for that joe so if we don't get a
hold of global warming we can expect to
see a lot more of this weather in the
future
so
we're outside because ellie is joining
us to talk about the euros and just for
a kick about hi ellie thanks for joining
us hi guys thanks for inviting me here
today so you've been campaigning for
ages for girls to have the same chances
as boys when it comes to football i mean
we're not even calling it the women's
euros anymore we're just calling it the
euros and there's been a record-breaking
number of tickets that have been sold so
do you think that girls are finally
getting the same opportunities as boys
are yeah definitely they've been classes
professional and elite just like the men
and grassroots game for younger girls
has grown massively and it just provides
a lot more opportunities for girls to
play football yeah definitely so do you
think it's time that professional women
footballers got the same wages as men
like they've done in the usa yeah
definitely usa is leading by example by
giving them both the same because of
drawing in the same crowd and playing
the same high level the rest of the
world should now follow an example
because it's just unfair not to so ellie
you've campaigned so much that you've
been made an ambassador for girls
football but what exactly does that mean
it means i'm a role model for girls in
my hometown to try and inspire them to
play football and i go to groups of
girls to speak to more about football
and try and inspire them so do you think
england has a shot of winning this year
yeah definitely especially when they
finish top of their group stage and
they're in good form to win it well
finally can you show me your football
skill and maya i think you'd better sit
this one out yeah definitely okay
so the skill i'm going to show you is
called the step over and you can use
your system to get round players when
they're coming at you and this is what
it looks like
okay you need to take your dominant foot
around the outside of the ball and then
kick it to the side okay
and then i kick it yeah okay i'll kick
it to you
okay you ready
well done scarlett i think i need a bit
more practice i mean i'm not as good as
you but football is a lot of fun
thanks for joining us ellie thanks for
inviting me today
summertime means loads of decent films
will be coming out and this one caught
my eye zombies three the third
installment at a school like no other
welcome back to seabrook
humans zombies and werewolves have
learned to live together
but now some newcomers arrive in
seabrook leading to more than just a
friendly cheerleading competition
we've got some of the stars of the film
joining us now
hi guys we love zombies and it's weird
but i also like the fact that there are
some serious messages that come out of
the storyline throughout the whole
franchise there's this underlying
theme message of acceptance but also um
the fact that you need to have hard
conversations um to to change and
improve yourself yeah and that we can
make like our planet here you know our
utopia hit a map to utopia a new home
for aliens
we came here to find it there's a big
theme of acceptance in the film and
obviously as the aliens being the
newcomers they had some problems fitting
in have you guys ever experienced
anything like that yourselves
i think it's an ongoing experience you
know i'm queer non-binary but i've been
fortunate in that like growing up i had
a very supportive friend group and stuff
but i think a lot of the acceptance
issues happen from societal acceptance
and i think you feel that in your bones
it's important to just embrace who you
are you know no matter what anybody
thinks and i think in order to progress
we need to continue
to be outwardly
and loudly ourselves yes so what advice
would you give to someone who's perhaps
moved schools or towns and is worried
about being accepted or fitting in i
remember you know doing things in school
because i felt like it would make me fit
in and the second i started you know
pursuing my dreams and following my
passions when i really felt like i
became such a happier person and if
people aren't being really supportive of
you and being nice to them they aren't
your true friends you don't want to be
around those people well thank you so
much for speaking to me guys
thank you so much
they're here to take what's ours
[Music]
well that's about it from us but before
we go here are some amazing images taken
by a nasa telescope the deepest and the
sharpest image ever taken of the
universe showing thousands of galaxies
and check out these images of an unseen
universe wow they're amazing see you
next time
[Music]
you